hey guys Pete here this is just going to
be a quick video today it's not
something i usually do but i was looking
at something earlier and i just wanted
to make a short video to talk about it
it will contain spoilers from filming of
season 7 so please don't watch if you
don't want to learn what's going on on
the set and with that let's jump right
into it so today I was looking over some
of the news related to the weekly
spoiler report video I'm gonna do on
Saturday most of you guys are familiar
with this since I do it every week and
try to be consistent about when I put it
out so during the week I look over all
the different news and information and
go down little rabbit holes you know
about what might be going on when
they're shooting the scenes I came
across this gallery on the highway
website and as I was flicking through
the photos I just thought about how good
of a time it is to be a game of Thrones
fan so I'm gonna go over these photos
first and what they are and then I'll
clarify my statement after the fact and
i'll just ask politely that you don't go
into like a nerd rage yet about what I
just said hear me out the photos are
from the scene that we've been talking
about for months the big ambush on the
Lannister army as they're traveling back
to King's Landing there's nothing really
new in these photos but what kept me
clicking back through the gallery over
and over was just how well developed the
whole entire scene looks and the obvious
fact that a dragon probably ripped
through here and took out this Caravan
which will look a whole lot more
spectacular once we see the CGI added to
it later I'll go way more into this in
the weekly video because this isn't even
though the entirety of all the shots
that came out of this three week filming
but I mean you can see in these photos
that it has this cable where the camera
can like you know swoop right in over
top of the entire battlefield and pretty
much the smoke machines make it look
like everything has been caught on fire
so if it looks this good now I can only
imagine what it's going to look like
after post-production I mean the actual
side by side of the caravan sitting
there and then the aftermath these two
photos alone make me really excited
about the upcoming season it made me
think about Braveheart the first time I
saw it you know though
battle scenes and I just thought about
it you know we have one of these minimum
in every season at this point so I just
wanted to share the photos early to get
the hype train started and get everyone
excited for the Saturday video and now
I'll get back into clarifying the
statement about what a good time it is
to be a game of Thrones fan after all
there's a lot of criticisms that could
be made about the show but I was just
looking at the scale of this actual
scene and what's probably going on in it
and thinking like there wasn't anything
else like this back in 2011 when the
show started there were good shows in
2011 I mean breaking bad was in full
stride and the first things in a
homeland came out that year which I
think was a really good first season
regardless of what you think about the
show in present time I mean I'm still a
fan i watch but I think out of all of it
the you know the first two seasons stand
out as the best to the walking dead was
rolling along although I'm not sure I
wasn't an early adopter of walking dead
I got into it a while after it was out
so I'm not sure if I was watching the
second season live I can't really
remember in the walking dead is great
but it's just one of those things that's
always there it's not something that I
get super hyped about other than when
I'm actually embroiled in the season
plus a couple all the shows were out to
like Boardwalk Empire which started out
strong the killing started that year
which i think was pretty good and of
course mad men had been around for a
while at that point but none of those
shows were like doing things like Game
of Thrones is doing right now and like I
said there's a lot of real ways you
could criticize the show and it's really
easy if that's what you really want to
do because obviously it doesn't live up
to the great world building that happens
in the book series and really they do
cut out a lot of stuff at you know like
i said it's easy to criticize if you
really want to but then again like I
said compare it to other shows of that
era and look where it's gone as far as
the production value is concerned like I
know personally in season six there were
a couple things that took away from the
whole enjoyment of the series for me
when I first watched but then you know I
after I calmed down and got out of my
little personal nerdrage fit about them
not following exactly the parts that I
wanted and you know like little details
about how people are moving around too
fast and you know all the silly stuff
that really doesn't affect the overall
experience and let unless I want it to I
mean I'm still not a fan of the you know
it was a great scene and put together
well I'm still not a fan of Arya getting
stabbed in the stomach and then doing
this Jason Bourne action scene right
afterwards but you know nothing's
perfect and I'm sure season 7 and season
8 won't be either but we're down to 13
hours left of this show though even
watching for all these years so I'm
going to enjoy the news that's coming
out and look forward to what we're going
to see because it really does look
awesome so I hope you guys will join me
on saturday i usually upload my weekly
spoiler report at around I don't know 10
a.m. east coast time us so I look
forward to hearing from you guys in the
comments on that I still have a book
giveaway going on so leave a comment
here after you subscribe for your chance
to win the 20th anniversary edition of a
game of thrones by george RR martin i'll
put a link in the description to that so
you can check it out if you haven't seen
it yet and the way the giveaway works is
really simple i just searched through
all the comments on all the videos that
are eligible for this particular
giveaway and then I picked the winner
using the random comment picker if
you're new to my channel and you're like
WTF this guy just rambled about a couple
pictures for a few minutes please check
out one of the links to one of my
previous videos there are a lot more
than that and if you're not new and
you're one of my regular subscribers let
me know what you think about the short
video format I was thinking about maybe
doing regular more regular updates and a
lot of the other videos just take a lot
more time to put together hit me up in
the comments thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon